going on is
there but my toe and my cut my
fingers and my
coordination there's not a lot
of so I'm trying to be hard with you all
I'm not I'm but what I'm saying
is let's say there's 20 of you in this
map tonight there should be 20 different
fifths of bires because I I should be
looking at 20
individuals I don't want to look at a
Sausage Factory where all the sausages
are the
same we have a style where
hey
hey hey you know somebody might go he's
a cyto Sensi student and I'd be pleased
if they say
it
but
if I don't move down
there and I start doing
this you see how jerky it's now becoming
cuz I have to sort of lunge into it all
of a
sudden so you want to spend as much time
as you
can
learning how to sense
[Applause]
yourself
see this is an aid to your advancement
in your body movement how are we doing
on time what time do we 25 minutes okay
so I'm just going to give you a little
break now uh Stuart and Co so they know
each other this is how I was trained all
right I'm just going to show you how I
was trained you're going to do the key
sub
noach so we start off with the
sauris this is then there's a part of
practice then there's a k not stop keep
there right to me and I hope to you they
look a bit tense don't
they yeah
see who so who's the attacker who direct
attacker Stuart Stuart
yeah and trouble is he's fth down he's
the he's the guy that's actually is the
attacker don't get it wrong can't you
see he's the attacker no of course you
can't you worked on your common
sense so he's got yeah what he's done by
the time I get over here he's decided to
soften a little
bit so there's two ways of doing the Kos
subot attach there's a long verse and a
short verse so we'll do the long one
first where they do the third subur each
do it again do it
again do it
again
okay see I didn't teach them anything
what I done was I said to them
concentrate
because if not it'll just become a load
of movements and I don't want a load of
movement
again
again so they've got to work out what
they're doing
wrong
carry
[Applause]
on that
again do it again
rabbish rabbish do it
[Music]
again don't do it again you mustn't ever
tap the Kens together
do it
again yes you must be timed with him but
you mustn't be waiting for
him push okay so at the end I want you
to see if you can come forward
now they'll be quite exhausted because
of their adrenaline and the
concentration stop do it again what's
wrong my
teacher who's the aggressive
one Stuart yeah and he's the one winning
so he should be saying please go par us
I don't want to fight you so he
shouldn't show this
forwardness do it again